طريق وعره يسلكها الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب للعوده الى البيت الابيض
متعثرا بالعديد من الحجاره التي تقف في
طريقه ولا ربما يصل لنهايه مسدوده لم تمر
ثلاثه اسابيع على حمله ترامب الرئاسيه
لعام 2024
لتنهال عليه المشاكل تباعا
[تصفيق]
رغم ان ترامب الوحيد الذي اعلنت ترشحه عن
الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه الا ان احتمالات
اعلان ترشح الرمز سانتوس حكيم فلوريدا
تثير القلق بالنسبه للرئيس السابق خاصه ان
استطلاعات الراي فضل الدسم الذي لم يترشح
بعد على ترامب
اكبر الاسماك في مسيره ترامب السياسيه
كانت اقتحام مؤيديه مبنى كابيتال لجنه
التحقيق في احداث السادس من يناير ستحل
التوصيات الجنائيه الى وزاره العدل ليصدر
القرار المؤثر في المستقبل ترامب السياسي
بعد الاستعلاء على الوثائق التي وجدت في
منزل ترامب اسقطت محكمه الاستئناف جهود
فريقه لتعيين خبيرا خاص لمراجعتها كما ان
المحكمه العليا رفضت محاولات ترامب لمنع
لجنتي مجلس النواب من الحصول على سجلاته
الضريبيه
[تصفيق]
هيئه محلفين في نيويورك ادانت منظمه ترامب
بالاحتلال والتهرب الضريبي قائله ان
المنظمه عملت على مدار 15 عاما لتنفيذ
المخطط التهرب ورغم ان الملياردير لم توجه
له اي تهمه الى ان المنظمه توجه غرامات
بقيمه مليون و600 الف دولار اما الاسوء
فهو النكسه المحتمله في طريق عودته للبيت
الابيض نتيجه التلوث سمعه المنظمه الى عمر
العربيه